hello welcome to another episode of gabe
spot plays I'm Daniel Dwyer joined by
mr. Andy Berman hey what's up Daniel
Dwyer you like race cars well I like
virtual race car okay you own a subaru
WRX yeah that's pretty good it's good
it's got turbo charger and stuff that's
not a car that's available in project
card CD Projekt cars which are about to
play here and project cars it which
means stands for community assistant
racing yeah this is the this is out on
playstation 4 xbox one on pc were
playing the pc version here i'm playing
with a steering wheel Hot Wheel idea
we've got a thrustmaster with some hot
pedals and he's got a big playstation
logo on it though what are you doing on
pc it does that the 300 you get drivers
for us to hook it up to pc so that's
something wrong yeah it's pretty rad a
bunch of cars your big more forts of
motorsport found but there's one way in
which this is completely different to 42
yeah it didn't the way that you can just
pick whatever track pick whatever car
and just do a race you don't have to
worry about um you know unlocking a or
you can do that for is it to be fair you
can say a free event to do it no but
those games you know focused around the
progression yes small start in your uh
you know kia sportage a I'm whatever and
there is kinda build up to the to the
bigger car you have to get credits you
do then buy it by him and it's actually
and you can do that in the career mode
here yeah you can start off with cards
and work your way through but but most
of it is just kind of there's a great
online component as well but yeah we're
gonna dive into soda it just so we can
show a couple of a couple of tracks and
couple of different race types cuz
there's loads look at this [ __ ] yeah at
all this nonsense yeah I mean forces net
cars that's cool but I have you know
track toys GT this is focused on cars
you're gonna see at a race track so
there are some road cars but you know
there will track focus road cars like it
the BMW m3 or the got everything I might
be one or what I got like p ones i got
like you asked our stuff like they've
got four minute a which is basically
formative one from like this guy i think
there's like the 2011 cars maybe you
know yeah look all these like little
super sports and like crazy old lotuses
like that like they're all like really
I detailed like this game looks really
fun it looks fantastic it also and
controls really well I this is one of
these games that I think you need to
play this with him like I played over
the controller and I just don't enjoy it
as much when they feel of grip in the
feel of that like how each car works
mechanically it's so unique that I think
you kind of need the wheel and then they
at least the wheel to sort of get the
most out of it you're correct a plan
with a gamepad no matter what system i
played it on all three over it now I'll
with the gamepad I've had to like tweak
it massively to give it the way I want
it really but luckily this game is so
like you know open to that you can go to
the menu do the steering sensitivity so
much tinkering yeah I think tinkering
that's a good way to put it and my game
do whatever you want yeah the cars you
can all tune like incredibly my new
details are ride height yeah
strength or whatever it is and they do
let you do some stuff that's kind of
like casual but I'm not playing filthy
casual i'm playing with i'm doing my own
gears I'm gonna yeah i know it's he's
for my real i am how about your reaction
control system I don't have it on but I
have a these cars have traction control
system in real life it's so hard to talk
and do this at the same time I've all
the difficulty tour of all the like
realistic stuff turned on as well so you
can just break you like suspension arms
and stuff yeah like damages on yeah real
it's on full wow so this is bobby plus
you're in the mode now that puts you in
the ailment which you can't we can you
turn off you can adjust all the camera
angles as well so like you put some
chemicals I'll take em take a curve a
grande here in Monza up oh really
freaking good at this this is uh not
easy let's no it's not Oh Mellie in one
of these cards these cars are so widely
oh no he's so wily like trying to I love
how it goes blurry so you could like I'm
just looking at the little blue lights
was like and that's how they kind of all
simulate the speed effects that are no
all right you're good you're still good
oh that's a bad one front oh you lost
the you know oh did I but there's
already lots will go to the I'll save
you let's check it out oh yeah oh that
does not look good you're gonna build a
race on them just get it back to the
pits this is I was gonna pull over the
picker the marshals need to we're gonna
have to get a safety car for this that
let's try a different race alright so
that's this game in a nutshell really
freakin hard really hard we're really
satisfying like I I enjoyed the
difficulty in this a lot so another like
differentiation from Forza is like you
just select a track a new race mmm and
maybe select how many laps or whatever
like but it's usually only like a couple
laps this this game it really wants you
two to be able to simulate a race
weekend it that's what it says it's like
you qualify you do your pits you do your
practice sessions I want to see how much
gas you're gonna need you can fill up
your guests to where you want it and
take pit stops and yeah not so high
right strategies which is like that's
all way over my head because I just you
know want to drive cars passed yeah well
it's something I'm used to being like a
form of the one fan because yeah that's
that's that's part and parcel with race
strategy is like making sure
you end the race with you know this
smallest amount of fuel in the tank so
that you're nice and light and skipping
along keep that acceleration at a but
it's across everything like it's across
all these different disciplines and you
were saying something very interesting
when we talked about this earlier which
was that this is the type of game where
instead of just unlocking the next car
and like trying to like mix it up like
that give any different cars to mix it
up in this game they're really trying to
get you to like perfect one type of dry
hair like find a car you like and then
freaking know that car yeah and then
know it on every track which can just
got your thousand your whole life pretty
much oh forgot too bad shifting at the
start I thought it was an f1 car and
like double shift it straight oh hey oh
man actually whoa that is what oh well a
lot of launch control will take you from
first to third different trying to go
services yeah it's over anyway uh we're
gonna ask you f1 so you're a fan of f1
why not play f1 like it's what's the
difference between this and that game oh
like exact it so that game controls like
it you know you can crank up the
difficulty yeah but Jesus Christ this is
I'm doing a poor showing here but that
game is very much a Arkady a lot on
arcade it sits in the middle and I feel
like most driving games have sat in the
middle for a long time like there's a
big difference between our factor and
you know drive club or even Gran Turismo
and stuff which was kind of realistic in
in some ways but then another ways was
just like oh god I forgot to shift again
you can tell you when you forget to
check out every night drives around yeah
because we don't have the TV set up I'm
actually sitting on a tiny little table
here as well so it's just nothing about
this is like how I was playing outside
and but yeah this game is realistic in
like completely different ways like in
many ways like the AI for instance isn't
fantastic in this game they're kind of
kind of they kind of they drift between
being incredibly clever to being like
just almost passive like they're just
kind of like let you let you fly by and
but those games feel like you're you're
you're that you know you're battling
everyone else this game is a game where
you feel like you're battling between
you and the car okay then there's a
that's a satisfying experience in the
cell totally get it
get into it it's very it's real
satisfying because then every car is
different as well so like I enjoyed
playing a porn game because it has all
you know has all licenses and all the
tracks and all that like obviously you
list it but you think I'm Monza and
Silverstone and they don't have a yes
greater they have Abu Dhabi or something
and I'm keeping spotted oh sorry spaza
as well absolutely and then you can like
eat if you want you can you can do spa
and a cars yep you can go up a rouge in
like a little tiny go-kart and you know
do do it five-minute laughs I might get
my place actually that's pretty good
this this is why I don't flake this
setup because my thank you battle the
Battle slipped out from underneath week
so that's what happens like Oscars there
do a little spinning spinning let's uh
let's try one more different type of I'm
just making cars now no I don't care
it's pretty good Carson mm-hmm ference
that's what your car sounds like oh man
hit that turbo [ __ ] and yeah but this is
it's it's a it's a real fun game I've
been jumping in and out of us for the
past that at two weeks just kind of you
know I've got an hour and I just want to
jump in and like try out a new different
like there's so much variety like look
at let's say we've we've shown kind of a
road track and then an actual circus GT
car oh FML Azana as well actually was
pretty cool and I like the goodness sake
a classic look at all the different
versions of the Nordschleife they have
here as well remember how 425 shipped
without the Nurburgring oh did your
right jack okay but they added it in so
that's good so we can do so we can do
stage 3 and just hit that Biggles yet if
you want is a great one yeah let's do
that what's the fount with more fast
cars on the honor he oh yeah this is it
the county quite right here as well
actually yeah how many of those in the
world and yeah so it's like I just love
jumping in and trying to add a like a
new new car new dumb situation or like
or really settling on like I've done you
wouldn't know from how I was thing just
there but I've like done a bunch of and
just playing around in Monza with like
different settings on the car as well so
here's a wire as oh that's do it and I
like it like you know we're very much
playing like vanilla too laughs just to
show you here but yeah you can crank
arguin crank up the opponent's you can
straight-up out like 36 apple and cars
on
thing as well let's do multi class okay
I'll be interesting opponents scale this
thing is weird it's there's never really
that clever yeah it does make them
harder just put it up leave it there I
found that uh I keep all my assist my
driving says on most not like steering
or breaking but uh traction brakes and
that's it yeah I keep those on and it
makes this game a little more enjoyable
because the feedback just isn't there to
like feather this stuff is it is
unfortunate and stuff like i can play
those games with all that off and have
an enjoyable experience and this one I
feel like I'm I should be making this
turn but I'm completely losing
controlling designs like I don't have
the feeling that I'm going too fast like
so I found there's some bounces yet to
like cut makeup or in this game me feel
about for yourself but once you do that
it's amazing in on PC like there's this
isn't on pc and fishing for dude I don't
know it's me or this yeah they've been
trying ever get like this appears for so
this is anomaly is it this happens to be
starting nordschleife with like 36 cars
it's just like and I was something that
in front like a Buju yeah somebody was
pushing me from behind there is also
lost a bit of truck I love this it was
great it's all just been getting that
right position for the most fat straight
later on yeah like from PS for crying
out for game like this like dr dog was a
huge disappointment yeah it's just so
dumb looking this is just like german
traffic that's like everybody's looking
cuz everybody's your uber car simulator
oh my god i love throwing on all the m
the damage and there's also like for
instance in the airport games you can
put on mechanical like mechanical issues
that just happen holy the car just
explodes yeah like just having problems
that you need to pit for ya
oh it's already here at sing I need to
hear it that's all not talking yeah so
the thing about yeah you talk a gopher
yeah thing about a pagani who is that is
best like real fast our friends over at
X car calm a sister site to a cbi di
they went and drove a witness to
pregardia that guy's been crazy it's
Italian some had some some car passion I
look at these guys there's something
like it's so satisfying about lining up
or partaking in this game like way more
than him when I play the f1 game and the
f1 game I almost feel like I'm keeping
overtaking because I've either said to
difficulty so low that they just don't
care or they've made a mistake like it
never feels like I a bottle for like
five laps to get that overtake and
sometimes it feels good but like for the
most part it doesn't really I kind of
like the fact that the AI and this
isn'ta cleverest like even if you like
I've set it up way hardness as well and
there never really doc clever they're
definitely aggressive so if you're if
you have like if you're like clamoring
for a bit of space they tend to kind of
give it to you you know ya know why I
drop down to 1st there and I've been
playing this game as over the last two
days well oh my god thanks bogani your
great he's got balloon that's probably
because I was like he's run just ran
driving it in red line to get on like
low gears alright engine blown I just so
over here you guys just raised without
me last year I've been testing this game
out look at my little though super high
resolution oye SI and it scales so well
it looks amazing apple cake I've also
been playing at 1080p at a hundred and
forty four frames oh my god really ok I
never monitor in that has 100.4 refresh
rate it's amazing I recommend all car
games be played that way I was better at
the game because it was so aggressive
and I could like look further down the
track and see I was gonna maybe or this
is all on my own head I've really better
but it was so good at that high frame
rate so like yeah we're clambering it
all racing game should be 60 pee on you
know xbox support yeah I needs to be 62
you're setting the benefit onna all
gazing 144 pinky know and this game will
do it for you if you have to set up is
it will but don't run 60 p
unlike most pcs probably yeah yeah it's
it's actually relatively well optimized
my pc at home is in the fastest saddest
thing in the world and i got 570 in and
looks good and it plays good too and i'm
gonna give this a go carts because it's
the other side of the spectrum I love
the carton it had a real sense of speed
that this game kind of don't have is it
better there's a better cover angle than
that yeah there we go these things are
crazy so this is like what f1 drivers
come up doing yeah they do boys like
some of them something like Lewis
Hamilton and Nico Rosberg I used to not
really know nothing about because it's
sooo theme this is so much fun oh now
you're good keep it at the cones that's
just a shortcut it's so hard I'm trying
to listen to my engine so but like
that's what I love about it it's like
the specially when you paid at the wheel
there's a mechanical sense like when you
go in like opposite of lock on Oh like
full lock on one of these things you're
kind of like feels like you're you're
battling the the terrain electron your
friends guys here when you're using the
wheel your hands on screen go they do
like over-under over-under if yeah crank
which if you're using a gamepad doesn't
do that oh really which is really nice
so it's almost like it's it's like like
directing you or something I know is
you're like struggling with it god I'm
really something alright nose using a
wheel and my inch is hopping up low
again good dancing that didn't with the
first hey he's Carter
yeah but these cars are fun I think
these big tracks take any other truck
for cars oh yeah pacific one in the
career boat that you use on the carts
and they're really fun all right all
right I got to take it seriously all
right yeah get in the zone maybe it's
the oddest escape from from Ferrari or
watching a Saturn you know what's
amazing though wasn't that good how much
I miss having the little indicator come
up in 45 like good turn sketchy turn
like that's got a lot here and just
isn't doesn't say it I kind of mailed
out that skin but I guess that wouldn't
be true to life in the reason in the
racing world yeah look I'm not going
down hill somewhere like I can't even
see that it's like rive kinder meter
LEDs on the top of my car yeah it's all
oh all right well I might as well finish
this race and so that's project cars
it's right now it's on a pc ps4 xbox one
apologies everyone for this horrific
driving at least something with a wheel
it was announced for Wii U but I don't
think that's I know I don't think that's
happening where yeah there's even if it
was you know what I gotta go and live it
was yeah I don't think plaintiff sort of
wii u gamepad like just like mario kart
style is probably the way you want to do
it it's 59 99 on PSN on xbox live on on
steam as well see a wise look it was a
wheel that weasel in the show all right
in that will ya paddles kept slipping
that's all gonna blame it on Andy ballon
hi thank you very much for chatting
favorite project comedy versity cancer
assault recon recon wait can we assisted
racing simulation simulator and for more
coverage of project cars perhaps with me
not sucking so bad as stay tuned to
gamespot com I'll do